how's it going bros my name is Pippa I'm
a little sick today
but the video cannot stop they never
stop you bros submissions for the
Photoshop pages contest whatever the
[ __ ] would call it I had so much fun
last one just going through all these
ridiculous pictures that you did what
the [ __ ]
well that's fapping material for later
alright alright alright you boys just
want me to have nightmares is that your
goal now this is art a tongue hat
beautiful fabulous there's like a TV
show
[ __ ] awesome TV show why now we're
talking quality what the [ __ ] man it's
kind of awesome
[Music]
sailor boots
chi Chi sila poacher oh come on
a cousin can
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] there's a
mermaid cute that is
yeah the [ __ ] man
oh hello new wallpaper [ __ ] yes yes that
Edgar in my crotch nice all right miss
you what that fabulous
Edgar hair though and my unicorn
thank you bros for making my dreams come
true
I really appreciate it how it would look
like if I was the president right here
[Laughter]
is that what I think it is no please god
no
[ __ ] sake salad ass I didn't actually I
don't know what this is but it's kind of
Awesome
I have duck eyes look at my a circular
when you're anime as [ __ ] [ __ ] sake
bros well here's the winner whoa dude
that's kind of all oh my god is that
making me nuts the duck King starring
Peter pie as duck
nice legs oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
we will break the internet to pay all
right listen
accurate representation of my youtube
channel right here this is amazing
10 out of 10 10 out of 10 baby that's
[ __ ] amazing fabulous good Ilya
Oh anyway as [ __ ]
okay we have a senpai Pierce and Pierce
separate fields notice just what the
[ __ ] is go okay alright alright alright
Matthew McConaughey now what the [ __ ] is
this
some of these are just [ __ ] grossest
[ __ ] winner we got it right here
other % now this is art right [ __ ]
here now this that is some fabulous
[ __ ] [ __ ] right there I love my
awkward side boob I got going thank you
oh not a thank you friends thank you
[ __ ] sake bras bro bored be hunt or be
hunted by the [ __ ] Lord nice I like
my brofist weapon okay alright alright I
can dig yeah what this [ __ ]
uh if there is a God I imagine this is
what he looks like
the rupocalypse the duck Appa lips I
don't know
ah nice ah fabulous
alright alright alright an accurate
representation of watching PewDiePie
videos what the [ __ ] am I looking at I
don't know alright Prez
this has been [ __ ] insane jesus
[ __ ] christ
233 pages how many entries was that in
total I don't even want to know but
thank you both so much for every single
one of them it really lifted my spirit
today to go through an easy one I'm sick
thank you for so much for what you do I
really appreciate it and it's really fun
to see that you're equally twisted in
the head as I am
alright Prez thank you for watching and
as always stay awesome ruse so I'm Edgar
and Edgar's me I look so happy about it
this is page one out of 200 great oh my